6 23 it's Thursday morning are you ready
to go all in we are talking poker this
morning but it's poker for charity
Heather that is right it's the charity
series a poker tournament with it some
delicious yummy food so joining us Matt
Stout you're from the actual charity
Series of Poker so you're gonna talk
about the game and Anna Gomes from via
Brazil's Steakhouse and Chef Fernando
who's been holding up meat I think for
20 minutes
so first let's talk about the game
itself because this is a charity game
and you're partnering with them to give
you all the food and drink where did
this how did this come about so I've
been playing poker for living since 2006
and in 2014 we started this as a
volunteer side project as a way for the
poker Community to give back some of our
favorite Charities so since then we
started off running events for Habitat
for Humanity and food banks and then
dang underground who asked me to take
over his big Saint Jude event and kind
of took off from there because I told
him to get the golden knights involved
and he's like wow the knights want to
sponsor it but they also want to run
their own charity poker tournament I
don't know how Okay this has gone from a
little volunteer side project to
something that's taken over kind of half
my life but it's all for a good cause
and that's important and we've helped
raise about three million for Golden
Knights Foundation Raiders Foundation St
Jude habitat food banks and some other
amazing causes amazing and and the event
that's coming up is of course over at
via Brazil which is uh the delicious
food Heather can barely country it
smells so darn good
um talk about your involvement here with
this nonprofit so yeah so we are going
to be serving 19 different varieties of
meats for the dinner as well as the bar
and side dishes the meat is right here
so I hope everybody's excited anyway so
we have a meatballs over here mac and
cheese salad mashed potatoes and rice so
I just want to make sure everybody's
going to come here and see us to the
beautiful event because we love hosting
those events we love our restaurant is
beautiful our restaurant is big and
that's why we are so happy to partner
with Matt with this beautiful big event
okay so we are inviting everyone to this
event and it's this month the 21st thank
you so much and even if you're terrible
at poker can you still have the food is
that okay that's okay because I'm
garbage yeah I'm not any good so I I
could use some some poker tips here what
do you got for me my husband was trying
to give me the info and I was like yeah
just be patient and aggressive wait for
good hands and then bet them hard wait a
second patient and aggressive seem like
the exact opposite things how do you do
both at once well you wait for the good
hands and then you pound away once again
so so if this is these are my two cards
you're doing all right
[Laughter]
average yeah oh my gosh the smell okay
so two Aces above average so I would be
doing good I would put it all in and
then I would just go all the chips head
over to the bar because you're doing
Unlimited
cocktails
all you can drink open bar vodka tequila
whiskey wine beer all you can drink
three hours a charity Series of Poker
event is happening February 21st at via
Brazil over on the west side of the
valley thank you all for coming in this
morning we really appreciate it it's a
great cause and uh looking forward to
hopefully winning some money everyone's
a winner yeah everyone is a winner
that's awesome thanks guys for being
here this morning